a lot of jews hate me because i'm so
i care deeply about the well-being of
palestinians and
and by the way i have someone who i know
in the music industry i thought you off
the camera i said yeah i was like i
don't think
i think rosenberg says some of the
injury gang they were like rosenberg is
a self-hating jew
and i was like jesus christ like
that's not true but all right i'll tell
you you might know the person i'll tell
you who it is later but
not on camera so exactly
i get self-hating jew because i care
about the well-being of palestinians but
on the flip side of that coin
because this is what this is what being
a measured thoughtful
person involved right um as a
jew when you see a lot of people just
putting up free palestine and and
even though you agree with that
sentiment if you know the person who
posted that doesn't know [ __ ] about the
subject
it is uncomfortable so it's hard to
explain and then and then if you add
even more to that
that you've also seen that person say
something else that seems a little
you might start to be like well do you
really care about palestine or do you
hate jews because that's not gonna get a
twist of people hate jews out here
yeah so anti-semitism is real we're
seeing in the street we see it in real
life so
it's a very uncomfortable thing to be
honest especially being someone who
thinks the israeli government is wrong
who wants
there to be a peaceful solution and i
have
jews who come after me and say i'm a
self-hater and then i have people on the
other side who say i'm a zionist monster
who doesn't
and the truth is i deeply care about
both that's how i was raised right
you know that that that is what my my
family evolved
my dad used to be militant pro-israel
militant right
in a time when it sends to be such right
right but
things have evolved right and now the
state of israel is in a different place
so
you know it's super uncomfortable but if
you can't be someone who's able to
acknowledge
that the israeli government is [ __ ] up
and that hamas is [ __ ] up if you're
not able to acknowledge
those things as possible i don't think
we can have a reasonable conversation